ضمن سياسه الاحتلال المتواصله في الضفه
الغربيه يسعى الاحتلال في هذه الليله
لاقتحام مدن الضفه الغربيه المحتله تحديدا
مدينه طولكرم حيث تظهر في هذه الصوره وصول
ما يزيد عن 25 اليه عسكريه من المحور
الغربي من المدينه هنا عند شارع السكه او
الطريق الواصله والتي تربط بضاحيه شويكه
بمدينه طول كرم ونسمع الان اصوات اشتباكات
مسلحه واطلاق للنار من بل قوات الاحتلال
التي اقتحمت الى منطقه او مدينه طول كرم
من محورها الغربي بعشرات الاليات العسكريه
والجرافات جرافات من طراز دي 9 وايضا
جرافات الدواليب التي وصلت هنا في
الاقتحام الذي وصل في هذه اللحظات وما
يزيد عن 25 اقتحاما لمدينه طول كرم منذ
السابع من اكتوبر هنا نرصد الاليات
العسكريه التي وصلت بالفعل الى مدينه طول
كرم ومرورا
بالمنطقه الشماليه دوار ما يسمى باو
الدوار الذي يربط ضاحيه شويكا بمدينه طول
كرم عشرات الاليات العسكريه التي وصلت
بالفعل في هذا الاقتحام وهناك تجمع كبير
لاليات الاحتلال العسكريه في هذه اللحظات
نتحدث عن اقتحام كبير لاليات الاحتلال
العسكريه والتي لا تزال حتى هذه اللحظه
تصل تباعا نحو مدينه طول كرم من البوابه
الغربيه ليث جعار الجزيره طول كرم
فلسطين